so how's this for a dummy moment when I
was a kid I thought there's only one
Narnia book The Lion the Witch in the
wardrobe I had no idea there were all
these sequels that it had threes I say
this is to point out quite clearly that
I never read the book to the sequel
Narnia Prince Caspian and I hear that
the people that did really don't like
the second one and even some people who
didn't don't really like the second one
either but I'll be honest I don't get it
in my opinion this is just as good if
not better than the first one it has a
much more heavy and dark tone as the
kids return to Narnia to find that it's
years later all the characters they knew
are gone and now this new dictatorship
has taken over and everything is in ruin
so the kids had to find their way to get
an army and win it back what I like
about this film is that it seems like
there's a lot more strategy and a lot
more talking about politics but in a
good way it felt to me like Game of
Thrones helped Peter Dinklage is friggin
in it and he does fantastic as usual but
I think there's more than that there's a
lot of talk about faith in this movie
you don't see much of a slant in it but
it's very selectively done
he appears in moments that tie into the
characters belief and I think that makes
a lot of sense there's also a lot about
temptation in the movie Peter has gotten
too cocky is afraid that he's lost his
way so the ghost of an evil past comes
in to try intentive sort of devilish if
you win I heard this wasn't in the
original book but I think it's great the
battle seemed much larger - they seem
more gradient harsh and adult it's not
just characters being turned to stone
you see them die you see them get
stabbed it's pretty intense but maybe
that's what a lot of people didn't like
about it there's not as many fantasy
characters of is they Moore's or show up
at the end and even then not that many I
like the fact that Peter was given more
of an arc in this one because I felt it
was desperately missing in the first one
the bad guy is great he definitely has
his villainous moments but you also see
he's still human
he's trying to do what's best for his
family line and will do absolutely
anything to make it happen
once again the ending does sort of come
around to it des uses machina kind of
like the first film and maybe that
through a lot of people off - like hey
didn't we get them the first film why
are we seeing this again
granted it's not the exact same one but
it is something that you didn't know
existed suddenly comes out and saves the
day but I did mine because I was totally
in the battle the whole time I was
rooting for the heroes I wanted to see
them save the day and I thought the
action scenes were really good and
really intense I guess for me I was
ready for something a little darker and
a little harsher but maybe that's not
what others were looking for and maybe
they didn't want to follow the book
closer like I said I haven't read it so
maybe they're right maybe the book did
do it better but as a straight forward
sequel I think it's pretty effective
check it out and draw your own
conclusions
you